- What I did this
morning was sign the bill
to finally eliminate their
self-governing status.
We've put the area into
state receivership.
I've appointed
people to manage it.
We now have the ability to
apply Florida law to them.
They used to be exempt
from the building code
and all these other things.
We also have the ability now
so that they'll pay their
fair share of taxes,
which they didn't have to
do for the last 60 years.
And of course, they're gonna
honor all the municipal debt
that they rung up, $700 million.
And so that is, basically,
treating them like
we treat SeaWorld.
They're gonna be
just another company.
(upbeat music)
- All right, people.
I'm not even doing a proper
intro for today's show.
You know the guy.
I end basically every one
of my daily shows with him,
the governor of the Free State
of Florida, Ron DeSantis.
Governor, how are you?
- I'm good.
How you doing?
- I'm all right.
I saw you at the Freedom
Conference this past weekend
and I said to you
that I'm not gonna bang you
up too much in this interview.
I have a feeling you'll
be okay through this one.
So look, everyone knows
how I feel about Florida.
Things are cooking, right?
Are you just feeling great
about how things are going here,
'cause that's really
how everyone's
feeling at the moment?
- Well, there's energy here.
And you're part of it,
because you were in a
place that really used
to be the the place
where people would go
for the American
Dream, California.
And to see people
coming 3,000 miles
to Florida and
being really happy
and feeling the
excitement and the energy,
it's really a unique time
in the history of the state.
But it didn't
happen by accident.
I mean, it really was a result
of us making certain
decisions that,
yes, we were gonna
be a free state.
Yes, we were not gonna end up
becoming a faustian dystopia.
Yes, we're gonna stand
for the right things
across the board.
And people have
really responded,
as you know, we're the fastest
growing state in the country.
We've led the nation in
net immigration every year
since I've been governor.
And what's happening in
California, Illinois, New York?
They're having net outmigration.
They're hemorrhaging people.
And yes, that's happened
in New York and Illinois
for a decent amount of time.
But California was never
a place people left.
They had never had
net outmigration
until four years ago, from
the time it was a state.
And so I think it's something
that people are very
sensitive about,
the state governments
that they live in.
There's a wide chasm
between quality of life
in a place like Florida
where woke goes to die
and some of these other places
where they're really
embracing woke ideology
to really devastating impacts
on things like public safety
where people don't feel safe
in some of these cities anymore
because so much of it's
governed by ideology
rather than the best
interests of the public.
- So you just bounced around
some of those blue states
and cities to talk
about law enforcement
and a couple of other things.
We played a bunch
of clips of you.
Were the local officials there,
maybe even the
Democrats, kind of like,
"Hey, Ron, thank
you for coming here,
and can somebody
fix this thing?"
I mean, are they
secretly, on the DL,
rooting for someone like you
to show up and fix things?
'Cause we just know it's not
happening in these blue cities.
- So it's interesting.
And the Chicago one
was the most publicized
because it was with the
Fraternal Order of Police,
a very powerful organization,
and it had been publicized,
I guess, a week in advance.
And so the left in
Illinois was really working
to gin up protest
against me when I came.
So I'm pulling in,
and this was like an
American Legion hall,
so they had to cap it.
There was capacity
for who could get in.
And I'm looking for
these protestors,
and I'm seeing all these
people outside kind
of hooting and hollering,
and they all had
signs welcoming me.
There were some protestors,
but there weren't very many.
But the rest were really
thankful for that.
And so I think the issue is,
is some of these politicians
cow-towel to the left,
the governor there, some of
these people running for mayor.
But I think you go
underneath that,
and particularly for
individual voters,
regardless if you're a
Republican or Democrat,
you know that what
they're doing is wrong.
When they just
abolished cash bail
at the beginning of the year,
New York did that and it failed.
Why would you go down that
road if you're Illinois?
Yet, they're doing it.
So I think people just
want some sanity imposed.
I think they like the
fact that Florida,
we really are common sense
about a lot of this stuff.
But we very much are proud
of being a place where
police officers wanna work,
because they know that it's
not just me supporting them
at the state government.
That's important,
'cause if you have a governor
that's not supportive,
it's bad for morale.
But you go to the
individual communities,
whether it's where you
are down in South Florida,
whether it's the panhandle,
people in the communities
genuinely appreciate the people
that wear the uniform and that
makes a difference for them.
- I'm down in south
Florida, below Miami.
I don't wanna say exactly,
but I met my local mayor here,
and he told me we have not
had a home break-in 14 years.
14 years!
It's just nuts.
All right, we have
limited time here.
So on the Disney front
and that whole fiasco
that seemingly has
just disappeared.
You kind of beat the kingdom.
Do you feel like you can
now kind of wash your hands
of this thing, and Disney
will behave differently,
and that there really will be
some concrete changes here?
- Well, actually, what I did
this morning was sign the bill
to finally eliminate their
self-governing status.
We've put the area into
state receivership.
I've appointed
people to manage it.
We now have the ability to
apply Florida law to them.
They used to be exempt
from the building code
and all these other things.
We also have the ability now
so that they'll pay their
fair share of taxes,
which they didn't have to
do for the last 60 years.
And of course, they're
gonna honor all the debts,
the municipal debt, that
they rung up, $700 million.
And so that is
basically treating them
like we treat SeaWorld.
They're gonna be
just another company.
And I wish everybody well in
Florida, but here's the thing.
They decided to take political
positions against our policy,
which they have a right to do.
Don't get me wrong.
But they did that
while enjoying this special
self-governing status
that no one else
in Florida enjoyed.
They did it while
enjoying subsidies
and exemptions and
all that stuff.
So it's basically,
they're going after our policy
and we're subsidizing
their activism.
So that was untenable.
So I think we had no
choice but to act.
And so, now, you
have a situation
where they had one of the
biggest sweetheart deals
in modern American history
and that is now up in smoke.
- So since the title
of the book is "The
Courage to Be Free",
I've heard you, obviously,
publicly and privately,
talk about fighting
with the media.
And I get a sense that
you really like it.
You kind of like when
they go after you.
It doesn't even matter
which side it's coming from.
Is that something that you
kind of learned on the job
or did you always have that
kind of innate courage yourself?
- Well, I think in terms of
just the courage to stand
for what's right and for
freedom, in this day and age,
as you know, so many of
the elite institutions
in our society, including
the media, but also big tech,
also the major corporations,
universities, the bureaucracy,
they are pursuing a more
woke left-of-center agenda.
And so if you're somebody
that's an impediment to that,
if I'm standing here
in Florida, and saying,
"No, no, not on my watch.
This is where woke goes to die."
Well, they're not
gonna like that,
and they're gonna come at you
and they're gonna shoot at you,
and you've gotta be
willing to take that
willing to fight back.
But if you're somebody that
thinks, in this day and age,
standing for the right
things is gonna be cost-free,
then you're in the
wrong line of work.
And so it's not
that you enjoy it,
but I view it as
positive feedback,
when I have all these Democrat
governors just attacking me,
unilaterally, I have the
New York media obsessed
with attacking me.
Well, they wouldn't
be doing that, Dave,
if I wasn't effective and if
I wasn't making a difference.
And so that tells me we're
on the right track and
we've gotta keep going.
But it's not just a guy like
me who's governing a big state.
Yeah, I'm a target.
You have parents that have
gone to school board meetings
to raise concerns about
some of the things
that are going on in the schools
and they get smeared by media.
Hell, Merrick Garland
wanted to mobilize the FBI
to go after some of the parents.
Whatever level you're at,
just know that there
will be some pushback.
But ultimately, if we wanna
maintain Florida as a free state
and if we wanna have a
revival across America,
where our true principles are
honored, that makes us unique,
you're gonna have to
fight these fights
and you are gonna have
to pay a certain price
in terms of what
people say about you
and the opposition
that you generate.
- Right, and we show the
pictures pretty much every day.
But the same media guys
who are going after you,
they end up vacationing
in Miami Beach
and the panhandle
and everywhere else.
All right, I will ask you,
actually, one tough one
so this isn't all
softball stuff.
In terms of the amount of
people that are coming here now,
and last I heard it was
about 1,200 people a day,
the one thing that seems to be
tough in Florida right now is
that housing prices are,
because of the amount
of people coming in,
housing prices are rising.
They seem to be rising
across the country
even in places
people are fleeing.
But what can be
done on that front
so that the OG
Floridians don't feel
like they're getting pushed out
and all the new people feel
like they can get a fair price?
- Yeah, no, it's
a great question.
I mean, on the one hand, we're
a victim of our own success
on that because the
demand is high to live,
particularly where you're at.
Well, one thing we are gonna do,
we're gonna accelerate a lot
of our infrastructure projects.
So I have a bunch of
projects in the hopper
that are important for
alleviating traffic,
all this stuff,
all across the state.
We're putting an
extra $7 billion in
so that I can get those done
13 years ahead of schedule.
'Cause some of these
are on a 20-year plan.
We don't have 20 years.
Too many people are coming.
So having that infrastructure
in place I think is important.
That can also make
it easier to continue
to build new housing.
We do have it going
up all over the state,
like never before,
but it still hasn't
kept pace with demand.
So the legislature
is gonna do a bill
to try to address some of
the needs in certain areas.
And it's not just
about the people
that can afford the big houses
in the suburbs that are nice.
We have a lot of people
who are very working class,
working jobs, maybe they're
waitress or something,
and it's hard to
find an apartment
in certain parts of the state.
So we wanna see more of
that type of housing be able
to be built.
So there's gonna be a
big package that's done,
and I think it'll help.
But at the end of the day,
we've always been a
state that's grown.
We are building,
but man, the growth
is outstripping
how fast these guys
can build the homes.
Now, of course, the inflation
has been a huge problem,
'cause construction costs
have gone through the roof.
So what used to be a home
in some excerpt for 250,000,
now that costs more so that
they gotta charge over 300,000,
put aside the demand,
and of course, the demand
drives it even higher.
- How much do you feel
like you're fighting
the federal government
on a daily basis?
I mean, obviously,
they cut FEMA kind of
early after Hurricane Ian.
The general stuff
with inflation, as
you just referenced,
the DIE stuff that we're
doing things here in Florida
that they're pushing federally.
I mean, do you really feel
like you're just constantly
at odds with them, and does
it even matter, I guess?
- Yeah, I mean, look,
I think that we are
protecting Floridians
with all that we've got
against the excesses
of the Biden administration.
I mean, for example,
they did the MRNA vax
mandate for the hospitals.
And that was done under CMS.
I had all these nurses,
they didn't wanna take it.
A lot of them had
already had COVID.
Many of them had concerns.
And so I didn't think they
should lose their job over that.
But they were gonna
impose this mandate.
However, they required the State
of Florida's hospital agency
to survey the hospitals
to ensure that the
vaxes were being done.
We rejected that.
We decided that we are
not gonna help this.
And so they didn't have the
ability to get the information.
They find us, which is fine.
Find me, I don't care.
We saved tens of
thousands of jobs
across the State of Florida.
So anytime we can step in and
protect people against this,
we do and we'll
continue to do it.
But here just shows
you what's going on
in the administration.
You know that the FDA forced
through emergency approval
for MNRA vax for
six-month old babies.
They didn't have data.
They didn't show
it was a benefit,
but they rammed it through.
Meanwhile, I've had an
application under 2003 law
that I did during
Trump's administration.
It's been sitting with Biden
for over two years at the FDA
where my state agencies can
purchase drugs from Canada.
The same drugs that
we already buy here.
They're just cheaper.
There's a provision
of law as we do it.
FDA says, "Well, we're
not sure it's safe."
So they'll stick
six-month old babies
with an MNRA shot on
an emergency basis,
but they won't let
me buy these drugs.
No, of course,
what they're doing is they're
basically running interference
for big pharma,
and that's typical of
what Biden's been doing.
So it's frustrating.
But I think that we've done...
And oh, by the way,
and maybe you can break
this when it happens,
we have a case in front of the
Northern District of Florida
in the panhandle
on Biden's catch-and-release
immigration amnesty policies.
We're gonna win that case.
It's been submitted
to the court.
We're just waiting
for the judge to rule.
We think it's gonna be
probably sometime in March,
and I think it's gonna
say his catch-and-release
is unconstitutional.
If that's (indistinct)
nationwide,
they're gonna have
to reevaluate their entire
open border policies.
So we're fighting
back on a daily basis.
- Well, governor,
you have blueprinted
this thing quite well
which is why me and
my family moved here
and I'm proud to be
in the fight with you.
And now, I got one more for you.
I know you're on a massive blitz
and you gotta get to
number one New York Times,
although the ultimate
credit would be
if they don't put you on at all
because then you can really
stick it to them, of course.
But is there any other sort
of announcement you
might wanna make,
or anything else you
might wanna talk about,
as long as we're
just chatting here,
anything else you wanna
say about anything?
Or, we could just end this now.
You tell me.
- Wouldn't you like to know?
I mean, that'd be
a good one for you.
But no, listen, I
appreciate your story,
and I'm really appreciative
that you really like
the State of Florida.
'Cause I have similar stories
and it makes us feel like
we're doing the right thing.
So if people go to
desantisbook.com,
they can see some
of the policies that
kind of led to that.
But when people stop
you on the street
and thank you for creating
a great environment,
that's why you get
into this business,
that's why you deal
with all the BS
that you gotta deal
with, because ultimately,
you're helping make
people's lives better
and we've been able
to do that here.
- Gov, I'll just tell
you one last thing.
So when I moved here
and I'm walking my dog
and everybody's coming up,
"Oh, you're the new
guys living over there."
And they say, "Where
are you from?"
And I'd go, "Cali, Los Angeles",
and they start freaking out.
So I realize what I should do
is I have to keep a picture
of me and you
together on my phone.
So when they say it, I go,
"No, no, no, I know this guy.
And then everybody's
like, "We're good."
Governor, the book's
gonna crush it.
I appreciate you.
You helped change my
life by getting me here
and my whole team
and two companies now
with Rumble and Locals.
So thank you and hope to see
you and the first lady soon.
- Okay, take care.
Thanks.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.